this has been another bruising round for
the conservatives
and at bolsover boxing club there are
quite a few looking out for their next
moves host Boris Johnson you vote for
Boris and then Boris sort of like let
everybody down who vote in conservative
Jordan Cobin because it was one rule for
them one rule for us because he's
chucked it out in I think
from a boxing point of view if I was his
caught him I'd shoot the talent for him
a long long time ago it's the right
thing to do Rosie I think he took to
Murray Sunday boss he did I won't be
voting conservative again
labor held this Derbyshire constituency
for decades but the former mining town
was part of the red wall that crumbled
to the Tories during the last general
election voters are split on whether
Boris Johnson will be back he had a way
of getting on with people I know it was
rather bombastic and whatnot but that
was his style
every prime minister has a different
style and I think it's a big pity that
he's had to leave on account of these
backbiters it's just gone to the point
of no return I think he's just pushed
the public you know no confidence in him
you know doing what he's done and I
don't think anybody's got any
and the uh heart for him anymore
Paul suggests that the majority of the
British public think that Boris Johnson
was right to resign most also think that
he knowingly misled Parliament over
partygate and most think it's likely
that he committed further covered
offenses something that he denies
Mr Johnson knows that the findings of
the party gate inquiry are due to be
published soon and some think the timing
of his resignation is significant he
bullies he uses his invective against
everybody who might stand in his way but
when it actually comes to the decisive
moment he jumps before the consequences
of his actions become apparent some
political experts think Johnson won't
find a way back I can't see a
parliamentary or political return in the
short term and probably not ever but
being no doubt Johnson is on the war
path he remains a powerful Communicator
he is his own best megaphone you know he
has one song to play and that was I was
robbed but more importantly he's free to
say now what he likes when he likes
without consequence or accountability
Boris Johnson was the reason the
conservatives won here with him out of
politics it's hard to know if they'll
find victory in their next major battle
Lisa Dowd Sky News bolsover